my archetype makes up a lot of the
internet white man
um there's never been a point the name
of a beautiful woman who might be a
dancer what's the backstory from New
Orleans or from I haven't thought that
through yet all right um yeah it's
ambiguous okay like an open world open
world I want you to project whatever
wherever you want Destiny the dancer to
be from that's in your mind okay all
right I'll save that for later tonight
yeah okay
as a white guy there I don't know if
there's ever been a spot that I've been
in where I've made been made to feel
like I don't belong there just by virtue
of who I am I don't I actually don't I
it's impossible for me to empathize that
because I don't even have that
experience if you go back eight nine
years one of the big issues that came up
was harassment and gaming against women
and I was one of the big Debaters
against that saying that like sure women
might get harassment but everybody gets
harassment if you're a woman and you're
in gaming and you get harassed
congratulations you're being treated
like a man what you're actually asking
for is for us to actually treat you
differently you don't want to be
insulted you don't want to be treated
like a man and that's actually misogyny
is women making that argument you still
stand by that is that a problem if I do
no I'm just kidding well okay hold on a
little it's a little while I disagree
with it sure okay that's good you should